hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason and I
joined today on uh this live stream our
annual annual weekly live stream with uh
Zach weismiller of Reason say hello Zach
hello and uh we are joined today by
Robert pondicio who's an education
analyst and expert at AEI the American
Enterprise Institute you wrote a
fantastic book about success academies
the charter school system uh you work at
the Fordham Institute and you were also
a school teacher in the South Bronx
right Robert uh I was it's been a few
years since I've been in the classroom
but uh the rest of those guilty as
charged yeah uh what was the name of the
book again I'm sorry I it was called how
the other half learns um two or three
years ago yeah and um that was uh you
know a fantastic work we talked about
that
um what's interesting about you
obviously is that you are a proponent of
school choice in the broadest terms
possible but you also call both
on a lot of things that are happening in
the public schools but also in the
private schools and so we're going to
talk about the varieties of school
choice and we're going to and we're also
going to talk about what's wrong with
Public Schools as well as private
schools including the wokeness of elite
prep schools everywhere which are the
worst of the bunch but let's start
talking about
um that what we use as the title for
this which I have now uh I I don't have
in front of me because of technical
issues how to read yes why did schools
stop teaching kids how to read maybe we
should call it why didn't they start
yeah let's uh let's talk about this you
wrote a uh uh an op-ed in the um uh New
York Post uh uh I don't know about eight
or nine months ago expert it is he on
teaching kids to read is behind Beyond
Comprehension
um what are you talking about there
what's the problem with the way kids are
taught to read
um one it's it's well it's complicated
all of these topics that you enumerated
up top Nick or are all complicated so
it's going to be a challenge to do
anything more than scratch the surface
in an hour
um but I mean you know at the risk of
being the guy who waves the bloody shirt
you know most of what I learned about
literacy I kind of learned the hard way
as a South Bronx fifth grade teacher and
to kind of set the scene I was uh you
know a second career teacher I had a
whole other career in life in the media
World
um until I was almost 40 and then then I
signed up to be um a fifth grade teacher
in the South Bronx for two years uh
under the the New York City teaching
fellows program uh two years turned into
five and and I never quite went back to
my my other life
partially because I became kind of
alarmed and militant about not just
weeding instruction but but but
curriculum at large in other words you
know at the time in the policy world
everybody was talking about uh you know
assessments and testing and
accountability and teacher quality and I
was like um can we talk about what the
kids do all day because that seems to
matter nobody seems to be talking about
it
so you know the the the the the my real
uh beef as it were with with the way I
was taught to teach uh reading and
writing frankly
um is that it is it made a lot of
mistake and assumptions not the least of
which is this idea that reading
comprehension is a skill
um and at the risk of wonking out a
little bit I mean it's important to kind
of think of reading as kind of like
having two main components the first is
what we call decoding you know the
ability to look at a piece of text and
translate those you know symbols into
into words and the second far more
prodigious challenge is is understanding
what the hell those words mean you know
so in other words there's there's the
quote skill of reading that is a skill I
could show you nonsense words right now
and even though they don't exist we
could all agree how they sound so to
speak but the much tougher not to crack
is is the comprehension piece
um and as you know Nick that's how I
became a disciple of Edie Hearst Jr and
his core knowledge and Cultural Literacy
views because as I've said I think I've
even said this to you he was the one guy
who described what I saw in my South
Bronx classroom every single day kids
who could decode for the most part but
struggled with comprehension and that
piece that you showed from the New York
Post was kind of like the the the
antithesis of that I was trained under
the methods uh taught by Lucy Hawkins of
teachers College which broadly speaking
said oh well look it has to be you know
the kids kids aren't reading because
they're bored they're disengaged you
know the curriculum isn't about their
interests you know so we need to make it
more about them so they'll be motivated
and engaged and Hirsch was the guy who's
like no it's background knowledge it's
vocabulary
um and and at the risk of over
summarizing hersch's right coffins as
well so let's talk a little bit about
this in in uh terms that uh kind of uh
certainly parents might understand or
anybody who's been reading you know
education kind of policy Arguments for
you know really 60 years how to
translate this into uh just how does
this intersect with arguments over whole
language learning to read and phonics
yeah I think mostly that's the first
part of that if what a colleague of mine
one's described reading is a two lock
box the first lock is the decoding piece
the second piece is the comprehension
piece so that's the first box
um you know and this is not new I mean
be somewhere behind me on that bookshelf
there's a book from 1955 called why
Johnny can't read right we were arguing
about this then before either one of us
uh Robert I'm just gonna ask you because
I think your microphone you're clicking
against it would you mind just why don't
you take the earbuds out completely
jacket maybe that might help okay
okay can we hear you now
I don't think so oh now put them back in
yeah okay put put it back in and just
keep the jacket zipped up
sorry this is we're having a little of a
technical rough start so this is our two
lock box here yeah
okay can you uh
uh you might have to oh you know what
he's muted so there yeah
I think he muted himself it says okay
there we go yeah thank you yeah and just
I will try not to talk with my hands and
uh and and looks like you guys got
booted off now so let's just keep
improvising here so anyway as I was as I
was saying in answer to your question
Nick if you can still hear me we've been
arguing about you know phonics versus
whole language for you know well over
half a century
um as far as I can tell back from you
know the Rudolph flesh book why Johnny
can't read in 1955. you know back then
we didn't call it whole language we
called it the look say method and and
why Johnny can't read
um you know took apart uh the the
so-called look say method and then you
know 30 years 40 years after that we had
the national reading panel you know
which was was put together uh by an act
in Congress which once again said it's
phonics basically I mean it's more
complicated than that but it it
reasserted that that phonics was was the
way to go
um so what we're having now is the the
latest version of an argument a debate
that has gone on for well over half a
century but but what's important here I
mean or part of your critique is and and
I apologize to our uh audience uh
because we're having technical issues
with the the program that we're using to
stream this so Robert is constant uh
Zach and I seem to be intermittent
perhaps a uh uh you know a kind of echo
of our shoddy academic careers or
something or in and out of the classroom
but
um no but from the AL Hague of reason
I'm in charge yeah yeah you can just
keep talking uh you know and just talk
as as much as you can for as long as you
can until somebody tells you to shut up
which I'm sure you're used to as a
school teacher but
um no so I I mean so part of this the
the phonics and uh whole language or
look-see method this you know that is
about decoding and basic yeah I I you
know it's hard to say like literacy I
mean it's like that people can
understand what the letters of the
alphabet are and the words that they
form Etc that's a big part of reading
absolutely you know if you use the code
you cannot read period and it's also one
of the things that is curious just to
bring up about why Johnny can't read you
know from the mid 50s a decade that
people like Bill Bennett the you know
former education secretary who wrote a
nation at risk and said you know what
everything was great in the 50s
the only thing teachers worried about
was kids chewing gum in the hallways or
something
um you know in fact when you look back
at the 1950s it was filled with anxiety
about the coming idiocracy of America
because you know kids were fat they
needed the Presidential Fitness stuff
you know the the Soviets were putting
satellites into space and we could not
read anymore there was a huge anxiety
about that so in a way education policy
and wonkery is always in a state of like
heightened anxiety you know so that that
I mean that's clear but is there a clear
difference between the efficacy of whole
language and and phonics in learning
that basic skill of how to read
yeah I mean I'm not sure I'm answering
your question directly but I mean if
with no phonics there's no there's no
reading I mean for what it's worth when
I was teaching in the South Bronx
um I never had a kid who couldn't decode
they could all decode so this is why I
became more of a comprehension guy yeah
look this is this is a blind spot on my
part I I I probably if you want to say
that I've been a little bit Blythe about
decoding over the years I'll I'll own
that that's probably true
um but I think because it's because it
is a skill it's easier to get kids I
shouldn't say easy easier to get kids to
the starting line of decoding
um and again this is not the question
you're asking but I think it's important
one of the big mistakes that we're at
risk of making right now is conflating
decoding and reading right if we get
every kid in America to to to to to the
decoding starting line by the end of
third grade one that would be a massive
achievement but that doesn't mean that
you know years from now we're going to
look at say fourth grade and eighth
grade nape reading scores and see a huge
Improvement because that second piece of
it the comprehension piece is is a much
much harder knot to crack so um you know
look I'm a big fan of what we're seeing
uh across the country in terms of some
of these laws and I know it's you know
it's an ironic thing to say to a reason
audience that I'm in favor of state laws
on reading uh we can talk about that if
you like
um but I mean we're there's a new
seriousness about getting kids to the
starting line of decoding that is that
is essential but it's really important
that we understand it's just the
starting line okay and so yeah well I do
want to kind of talk about that though
like how do school choice Advocates like
us uh cope with the widespread adoption
of what seems like a clearly flawed
teaching strategy yeah you could see it
like I I don't know if like school
choice necessarily solves it because
then you know it it's not necessarily
just infiltrating only district schools
and uh in a way like a more fragmented
system might might be more open to that
that sort of infiltration look you Nick
um kind of uh alluded to my calling
on both sides up top and this
is one of those areas in which I've made
myself a little bit unpopular with with
our school choice friends
um I mean I can't tell you how many
times I've you know given talks or you
know been been on panels where I where I
kind of say this to to school choice and
and also to end reform people it's like
you know if you think about the internal
logic of Education reform and testing
for the last 20 or 30 years we have this
idea that oh teachers know what to do we
just need to hold them accountable or or
I guess the choice version of that would
be to say oh there's all this you know
this this this untapped capacity out
there in excellence that just needs to
be freed from bureaucracy and red tape
like where the hell did you get that
idea
um because I promise you it's not true
um I mean I I use the example in my old
school of saying you know this was not a
a school where you had you know lazy
Union adults layabouts you know waiting
to to hit their their 30 years and 25
years of or 55 years old and 25 years of
service punching the clock and counting
the days it was mostly you know what
I've described as good people trying
hard and failing and not failing despite
their training but failing because of
their training you know so if if we have
this idea that either teachers are
phoning it in
and and and and would do better if only
we held their feet to the fire or they
already know what to do and we don't let
them you got to let that go that is that
is simply not the case
um you know we we have had any number of
kind of demonstrably bad ideas again
about reading comprehension in
particular that don't go away either
through accountability or because of
school choice
why does it keep happening though like
what is so appealing about something
like Lucy Calkins approach so many yeah
that's really easy
um I was just telling somebody this
yesterday because these are ideas that
are obvious intuitive engaging sexy and
dead wrong you know in other words if if
to broadly over summarize I think the
big mistake we make is assuming that
reading comprehension and I'm sorry for
dwelling upon those distinctions but
they're important that this idea that
reading comprehension is a skill like
throwing a ball or riding a bike that it
doesn't matter what you read as long as
you're reading and you know that you're
going to become a proficient reader and
that's just not so um you know back to
the Hersh thing you've got to have a
whole broad body of background knowledge
um because uh you know language
comprehension
broadly oversimplified it's a it's a
kind of shorthand you know that we we
every conversation we have everything
literate speakers and writers assume
their audiences are operating with the
same you know schema the same broad body
of background and knowledge and when
that's true conversation is is fluid I
mean it's it's almost like you know the
words we are using are the tip of the
iceberg and below the water line is a
whole lot of context vocabulary
um ambiguities around words I mean if
they think of the word shot for example
simple word shot everybody knows what it
is every kid comes to school knowing
that word shot well it means a very
different thing on a basketball court in
a doctor's office and a rifle range in a
bar you know if you don't know those
contexts and and and this is one example
but all of languages like that our most
simple utterances rely on shared
background knowledge and shared context
um sorry that was a long discursive
answer can I well well uh two things
just to ask about
is it clear that Cultural Literacy uh
you know has declined and and Hirsch was
writing at the you know what at the end
of the 80s uh yeah that's about right
um Nick's gone again so I'll just I'll
just I'll just run with that question
um yeah I mean you know language is a
cultural construct and and uh it's
uncomfortable to talk about this but I
mean there is a dominant language
culture and it relies a lot on the
idioms and cultural illusions of that
that people assume you know so is it
different well let's say for example we
decide oh we're not going to teach Greek
myths anymore because you know that's
that's white supremacy culture well then
years from now when when a you know one
of my former students is at a job
interview and somebody makes a reference
to opening Pandora's box or somebody's
Achilles heel and the kid goes huh
what's that well you know that doesn't
mean that the kid is dumb doesn't mean
the kid is poorly educated it means
somebody along the way made a decision
that you don't need to know that
um fine we can make that decision as an
educator but that person who might hire
him or her across the desk might think
differently how could that kid not know
Pandora's Box after that kidnap no
Achilles heel everybody knows that and
then you make a judgment and someone
else gets the job so you know this is
this is the message I always preach to
teachers is I don't want to be the guy
who tells you what kids should know and
what they don't need to know but just
understand that those are high stakes uh
decisions with real consequences for
kids so the the challenge here is uh you
know maybe there is a need for Cultural
Literacy or there's kind of a broad
understanding that certain teaching
methods are bad in certain teaching
methods are better but it's the the idea
of getting to to that truth and and how
it gets applied across the system and so
that then that's where these questions
of you know school choice versus like
District or state level management come
in so where do you draw those lines
because I mean I guess like my
inclination as as someone who's very Pro
school choice bullish on school cool
Choice like it's that these kind of have
to be worked out and like the cream will
rise to the top versus implemented uh
from the top down but does that have
limitations as to how far it can be
applied yeah it has here's I mean remind
me Zach because I do want to go back and
kind of you know talk about the the Lucy
caulking stuff and what happens when we
assume that um you know kids just need
to read and it doesn't matter what they
read because I think that's a lot of you
know how these pedagogies kind of take
effect because they they feel good
they're engaging for kids
um but you know the the answer to your
question I think you know and again you
know I'm a school choice guy
Unapologetic I you know I chose my
daughter's school I want you to choose
your kids school period full stop
um
but there's an opportunity cost here so
so let's say for example
um you know in other words if teachers
have been making this mistake for for
dozens of years why do we think parents
are going to be better at uh being
critical consumers of of
um you know uh instructional materials
pedagogy and whatnot so you might get
that might make a bad choice okay and
then your child's education will be
harmed and good for the rest of us we're
now learning from your example so it'll
be better for your grandkids
um but but you know your kid only gets
to be in fourth grade one time you know
and if and and if the model the
curriculum that you chose the school
that you chose is is holding on to bad
ideas about literacy well okay you know
there there's you have no one to blame
but yourself I suppose
um unless worried frankly about you know
the the engaged parent
um you know who who uh can be a Savvy
consumer of of curriculum and school
culture and whatnot that then I am the
the families that I used to work with
you know whether in South Bronx or
Harlem I mean I would see you know and
and I want to be careful here and I want
to suggest that they can't make good
decisions they can
um and do
um uh but there's there's there's always
going to be a problem in education with
camp followers okay this is an unlovely
thing that we never like to talk about
with Choice
um you know we we spend billions of
dollars on education and that's a rich
you know Target of opportunity for a lot
of folks who who you know are not
necessarily cognitive scientists and
well-versed and whatnot and are
perfectly happy to cash the check and
move on
um so you know you got to be you can't
assume I think that every parent is
going to be um you know have be very
clear-eyed about this and that there
aren't some unscrupulous motivations
among people who will rush into the
Choice market that's all does that mean
I'm not does that make me a bad choice
Advocate okay maybe it does but I think
it makes me a realistic one
right so then what what do you do with
that information like how how far I
guess are you willing to push uh school
choice because the the question always
is
um you know and we'll probably get into
some of the the states that have passed
these education savings accounts laws
that's kind of like the latest Frontier
in school choice where are you uh just
kind of give the parents
um or it's kind of framed as refunding
them some tax the the tax money and
they're able to use it at a private
school and then the question that you
know we Libertarians over here always
have is well are there going to be
strings attached to that are there going
to be conditions attached to that it
sounds like you might be saying that
there there should be some level of
spring attached maybe not how do you
think about that this is this is kind of
where I stare at my shoes and change the
subject
because I just don't really have a good
answer for you I mean what one look I
think it's incredibly naive to think
that you're going to take Public Funding
altogether out of
um education you know it it just that
that world doesn't exist and it's not
going to the idea that you're just going
to say trust it makes no more sense to
say trust parents and send send more
money than when the teachers union would
say just trust teachers and and send
more money you know public dollars yeah
well and we should also point out in in
a profound way public schooling to uh uh
to uh paraphrase Stokely Carmichael
public schooling as as American as
violence and Cherry Pie I mean it really
goes back to the colonial era where
there was publicly pooled money so I
don't we don't have to litigate whether
or not there's going to be public money
in education but then what are those we
might Nick we might have to litigate
that because there are some especially
frankly on the libertarian right sure
there should be no government role
whatsoever and what do you do with the
60 of kids who are not gonna either
homeschool or yeah well I mean I'll I'll
say this within the uh you know kind of
political battles right now the right
which broadly speaking is the one that
wants to separate state from school they
don't want to do that because they want
to be able to control it and we're going
to talk about Ron desantis's forays into
curriculum development in Florida or
Devolution uh in a bit but
um what are the limits let's just say
this like because and it's true you know
I grew up in New Jersey most I went to
Catholic school there the state had
certain requirements of all schools that
you know got tax breaks and things like
that so you know it's already there what
are the limits that you would put in
place on let's say backpack funding you
know you get in Arizona six thousand
seven thousand dollars whatever it is is
going to go to the kid they can use it
for basically anything what kind of
school do you say not that one or what
kind of expense where if the parents say
you know what we're going to do
Disneyland and they're going to learn
about Pirates of the Caribbean there
would you you know like how do you how
do you create a policy that you know
yeah it's it's a good question I mean
I'm I'm probably a lot more
um you know libertarian in that regard
uh you know I guess the way I would say
that is look I as you can tell I have
some very
well-defined ideas about you know good
better and best in terms of schools good
better and best in terms of curriculum I
don't want to be the guy that imposes
those ideas I want to persuade you to to
adopt some of my ideas but I don't want
to compel you about the the only thing
that I think I would probably compel is
is decoding is is Early Childhood
literacy you know in other words if you
want to take public dollars you've got
to get kids to to to the decoding line
um and then which would invalidate like
you know most of the schools in New York
right most of the Public Schools they're
not I mean seriously but like you know
the the early nape scores the national
assessment of educational progress what
do they have what you know what are the
proficiency levels it's got to be below
50 right oh I think that's right yeah I
mean depending on you know in the in the
New York Times article on this they were
estimating about a quarter of elementary
schools employ Lucy Hawkins method so
that's a huge I bet it's more than that
in fact well can I right you know
because I was in and out due to
technical difficulties which are really
a form of original sin I went to
Catholic school but learned how to read
anyway
um but I put everything in terms of why
did uh and I apologize if you've
answered this but why did going from
teaching reading like the first part of
decoding why is that necessarily even
from a progressive point of view why
does that mean okay we're not going to
teach Cultural Literacy because
yeah I I think I think we can broadly
separate those those two things okay um
I mean the whole language versus phonics
debate versus the you know the Cultural
Literacy versus let a thousand flowers
bloom what kind of I mean they're
related you know there's a flu line from
one to the other but they're but they're
they're distinctly different arguments
yeah okay
um but then if we're talking about the
kind of I mean then is the problem with
the the Lucy Cochin style reading uh
stuff is it that the kids don't even get
to the decoding line no no I again I I
think they do get to the decoding line
the the problem and we started to talk
about this and either we got diverted by
technical problems or maybe I diverted
myself as I sometimes do the the the
problem with the Caulkins method I don't
mean to single her out unfairly a lot of
folks adopt this I mean you know on the
shelf behind me is a ton of books that
are dedicated to to teaching I would say
badly and I mean School teaching scores
and you know the general feel about it
you know it sucked for the 20 years
prior to her kind of yeah but I I think
again a lot of this conversation will be
broadly oversimplifying and here's
another example we have this idea that
is still dominant
um and Lucy's the poster child for this
in many ways that reading comprehension
is a skill that you can that you can
practice comprehension strategies and
skills the same way you can practice
riding a bike or throwing a ball and
that's simply not so it's heavily
dependent on background knowledge and
vocabulary so if you are a a Caulkins
Advocate you would say as long as the
kids are reading well let's let's engage
them let's make sure that the that
they're reading stuff about their
interests about their lives you know and
and that will as long as they're
practicing the skill of of reading then
then they're going to become better
readers there's a grain of Truth to that
I mean and it has to do with a lot of
technical stuff about how even the
language of children's books has more
rare and unique words than than than our
conversation as college graduates for
example so there's there's something
there
um but but uh you know again you have to
read broadly because of um you know you
have to build schema you have to build
vocabulary and you're unlikely to do
that if all you ever do doing is reading
about your own experiences and interests
worse Nick you get kind of a false
positive you know you you can see kids
doing what feels like fairly
sophisticated comprehension work when
it's about topics they know but when the
test comes and they they're suddenly
reading about a subject they don't know
it's as if their brain has fallen out of
their head and you think as a teacher
what happened we worked on these skills
it's like but they're not a skill at all
yeah this is not there's a lot of yeah
there's a lot of domain specific
knowledge right which is and I I think
about this I don't know if you guys have
seen Glass Onion but uh I'll wrap that
in but you know there's a neon musk
style billionaire who's kind of an idiot
and you know what I think is right and
there's a French sociologist named
Pierre bourdough who talked about uh
cultural capital but that what happens
constantly is that people who have
success in one area say making a billion
dollars in business because they're
really good at selling Widgets or a
certain type of food or something like
that they start to think well I'm
brilliant in this field so when I start
discoursing about public policy or about
nutrition or whatever or celebrities who
are really good at making movies
you know start telling you about like
you know what you should eat or what
kinds of you know rocks you should shove
off your vagina like it's all equal to
them because they're brilliant to
everything
and in a way our Public Schools not our
Public School System our school system
uh has gravitated more and more to tell
kids you are a genius you are so smart
everything you do is kind of smart
main specific stuff like I know some
things really well and then I can kind
of fake it because there are certain
kinds of matrices of understanding or
analysis that you can play everywhere
but man you know it's like you got to
know something to know what it's about
no question look there was a fantastic
paper uh written uh Dan Willingham my my
buddy who's a cognitive scientist at the
University of Virginia loves to talk
about this best best paper ever it was
the title was could Steven Spielberg
manage the Yankees and then the answer
is no you know you're a creative genius
but you're a creative genius filmmaker
so and interest and look this is this is
a really an important point if you think
about the things that we talk about all
the time as the desired ends of
schooling uh we don't we don't want kids
to be you know compliance driven
automatons we want them to be problem
solvers and communicators and
collaborators and critical thinkers well
those are all domain specific things
right you know just like Steven
Spielberg couldn't manage the Yankees
um you can't be you can't make kids
all-purpose critical thinkers and
problem solvers all of this stuff is is
is domain specific you know you and I
could not have this conversation you
know and and come up with insightful you
know insights into fields we just don't
know having said that and this is kind
of taking us far afield from the the
kind of juicier topics we can talk about
there is something and I you know uh as
an undergrad I was a psychology major
which is to say I know less about
psychology than people who are English
Majors which I also was but
um you know I I worked with a lot of
people who were heavily influenced by
Jean Piaget who you know most of his
work is questionable because he like
observed his own kids in the 15 minutes
when his wife wasn't taking care of them
and generated these theories but there's
some stuff to be gained from that and
part of it is that if you know what
works in the domain you're you are
specific and you can start to abstract
certain kind of idea you know basic best
practices of critical thinking or
critical inquiry and that's part of what
education is about right is that become
competent at this one thing and then
let's start moving into other areas and
you can bring some of the skills like
sociology you know like if you bring a
sociological approach to literature
that's kind of interesting it doesn't
mean that you shouldn't also know
literary history Etc and you know vice
versa but um I feel like we're in kind
of in and the miasma of kind of
educational discussion and unfortunately
in education schools a lot of the times
there isn't enough attention paid to the
idea that you know you got to learn the
Canon or you got to learn the the you
know what this discourse Community
really believes
um to be expert at that and then maybe
you can find novel insights in other
areas but you know let's be
epistemologically humble and figure we
got a lot of learning to do well well
said we do this all the time in
education like we're not going to teach
history we're going to teach you to
think like a historian we're not going
to teach you science we're going to
teach you to you know to to think like a
scientist and that just becomes history
and science appreciation you don't
actually and I want to turn it over to
Zach for a second but just I want
because I want to you know bring up the
fact that you have a very Italian last
name uh because my mother was very
Italian and uh you know I we were
talking before our grandparents came
over roughly the same time in the 19
teens my mother and my father who's the
son of Irish immigrants grew up in New
York work in Manhattan and Brooklyn they
to the to their dying days in the 90s
they could tell me that you know bauxite
was the third you know most uh valuable
commodity mined out of Montana et cetera
like they grew up in the Golden Age of
you know American public schools as the
uh you know the place the Melting Pot
and where you learn knowledge and there
wasn't all this and like you
know they you know the teachers told you
you were all stupid and would amount to
nothing and and I you know can you
rescue like can you talk a little bit
about that because what they they were
taught a lot of facts that stuck with
them I mean like 70 years later 50 60
years later but they were not taught any
analytics they were not taught any you
know it didn't appear at least from the
way they talked about stuff they were
not educated Beyond you know grammar
school in high school but so I mean like
as bad as education is now is it worse
than what it was when we looked back can
say like oh that was the Heyday yeah I
mean I don't want to be that guy who
says well back in the day but I I do
think there's some wisdom to that
um that that and I think it's you know
it's almost as if that we think you know
that that it's like educational search
for the Northwest Passage that doesn't
exist we're going to find a shortcut to
these things
um and and it's a false dichotomy but I
think as a practical matter it's a real
one every time we think no we're just
going to teach these skills it's at the
expense of knowledge you know who's
knowledge oh you can just Google it well
no you can't you can't use those tools
effectively without a certain amount of
background knowledge so I'm not
suggesting that we we were good at this
and then lost our way even if we were
good at it accidentally you know it was
probably you'd probably be better off I
mean nobody wants you know the grad
grind school where you know the Battle
of Hastings that like you see an old you
know English movies
um but I mean in education that is
content Rich that is knowledge Rich at
the expense of these higher order
thinking skills would I'm not saying
it's good but if you had to choose a
school that just tried thought that it
could teach one and failed and one that
made no no attempt to you'd probably
back your way into more educated people
by By ignoring them all together uh and
let me be clear I am not advocating that
but I'm just answering the question that
you posed yeah no thank you Zach what is
the role of you know you're talking
about test scores a little bit earlier
I'm just going to display a couple of
the trends over time here this is uh the
Dead Man's EKG you got up there
yes I'm totally flat uh I think it's a
remarkable weight level for a late
middle-aged man I don't know I'm
impressed by that yeah it's a very
slight incline and then a kind of
reversion in recent years that's the
what we call the pandemic learning loss
um this is for mathematics these are
national uh math scores uh this is
um reading uh same story
what all the code he's flatlined yeah
what is the role of of test of testing
in in general and how it shapes the
education system like how how focused
should we be on on these numbers
um and especially when we're talking
about school choice because
um the the data on that and and maybe
you can I know you're steeped in it so
you can talk about you know what effect
do charter schools have on on it I mean
there's this is just one study I pulled
from education next which is generally a
pro Charter organization and showing
that uh in districts that have charter
schools in them there's
um a slight Improvement in in scores
across the district even in the in the
public schools um it's it's it's a
modest effect though
um and and there is earlier work that
shows in urban districts where there's a
lot of Catholic schools that provided
competition that that kind of boosts
every Everybody UPS their game when
there's more when there's more Choice
involved where there are more options it
seems like it has a positive effect and
I mean your book is is about Success
Academy which is very focused on that
and does achieve a pretty remarkable
results this one um you know very famous
and uh controversial Charter network but
you know there's questions about like
system-wide what would the effect be on
is that something that like how
concerned should people like us who who
are you know Pro school choice be with
those numbers and or or are there other
things beyond that we should be thinking
about yeah those are two very different
um uh veins of War to mine but let's
let's put a pin briefly in testing and
come back to it whatever the one thing I
want to say about testing is I'm not
anti-testing at all
um uh but it but it's con it has it's
had a very complicated effect on School
curriculum and culture and nobody should
sentimentalize the days before testing
um it has it has not been an unalloid
good um it's resulted in a lot of bad
practice like some of these practices we
were discussing earlier are incentivized
by by misconceptions there is definitely
we all have either have kids in the
educational system K through 12 or a
higher ed or we've all had kids
um teaching to the test is real and it's
spectacular
I don't know and by that I by that by
that I mean it it it is absolutely a
focus uh but it's not clear that trying
to do well on whatever tests we're
talking about really has anything to do
with making your kid you know more
educated the bromide is is it a test
test worth teaching to I I can see my
way to teaching to the test in math
because that really can be skills driven
in reading it probably does more harm
than good let's come back to that if we
must okay I'm Gonna Be a Jerk on the
charter school stuff because since I've
you know since you know I'm pro-charter
I'm pro-choice I get kind of aggravated
by the these distinctions you know when
you when you compare Charter results to
to to district schools because frankly
as an educator knowing if a school is a
charter or a district school tells me
absolutely nothing of value like what's
happening inside of that Charter what's
happening inside of that of that
District school are they teaching Lucy
Calkins are they teaching is it a core
knowledge school is it classical school
is it Montessori it tells me absolutely
nothing of value so I mean you could
make the case and you know that that you
know Charters with with their in theory
Here We Go Again Charters by dinta the
fact that they are free to you know hire
and fire their non-union they can you
know they they can you know make better
choices uh about curriculum Etc
I want to know what the decisions
they're making because to be really
honest there's no excuse for Charters to
be a little bit better they should be a
lot better so let me ask uh kind of the
same question from a slightly different
angle if you look at uh parental
satisfaction of Schools traditional
assignment public schools are here uh
charts public schools of choice are here
and then private schools are up here
um and that seems pretty ambiguous is
Parental satisfaction the main measure
that we should use in evaluating and
then to make that more complicated how
do parents know and I say this as you
know are you going to have any easy
questions today yes no no my ex-wife and
I are both phds and we you know our kids
went to uh K-12 uh Public Schools mostly
in uh in Southwestern Ohio and we were
like I don't have you know you get the
state report card blah blah blah not in
the school district which is kind of
good to have but like we had no
idea like when our kids came home with
books to learn how to read or to do math
like I don't know how to evaluate that
so my question is is Parental
satisfaction the you know the kind of
ultimate yardstick and how does that
relate to just getting meaningful
information about whether or not what a
school is doing and whether or not it's
effective it's it is a better
um yardstick than many of the others
maybe even most of the others you know
it's something I always say about school
choice is like when people say does
school choice work and they compare test
scores like well here's my barometer for
the school choice work yeah did you get
to choose do you like your choice if the
answer is about both of those questions
is yes then school choice works for you
um here I'm going to make another
comment that will put me in bad odor
with our choice friends
um we like to say among Choice folks
that you know parents should be in
control of their money well it's not
just their money you know I I pay taxes
to the Greenville School District even
though my daughter's 24 years old and
never spent a day in in Greenville New
York schools I still have a literal
vested interest I just wrote the check
you know so so it's it we're putting
parents in control of our money so from
an accountability question are parents a
better or are better
um uh
levers of accountability and test scores
yeah probably because they've got that
well certainly for their kids for their
kids but not for my tax dollars
so it's it's you you're not going to
have a perfect accountability system by
saying either trust test scores trust
parents it's always going to have to be
some kind of you know informed push and
pull between the various stakeholders in
public education that's no bad choice a
proponent then I'm a bad choice if if I
may also just to make it more
complicated still you know part of
education and certainly K through 12
it's not about you know book learning or
anything like that it's it's about you
know these vaguely determined uh morals
uh questions or their culture that I
want for my kid my parents although they
literally couldn't afford it uh and I
ended up paying for part of it uh they
sent me to a bad uh series of parochial
schools including a high school in
Middletown New Jersey modern day that
went out of business uh you know because
it sucks up at it recently went out of
business but you know they would say we
wanted you to have those values and then
you know when it comes to school trips
especially in the K-12 thing how do we
you know how do how do we talk about
about that and how do we factor that in
uh yeah you know because part of the the
promise of charter schools and of a
broad school choice certainly with
backpack funding or esa's is that there
is going to be a kung fu academy uh you
know where your kid will get you know
he'll graduate he'll be able to read or
she'll be able to read and write and do
arithmetic and she's going to have a
black belt in Taekwondo or something
like that and that might be great I mean
actually I would love that I would love
to see like a bunch of different schools
saying we're gonna we're gonna teach
your kids you know basic stuff and we're
going to Route it around sports or you
know science projects or whatever
um or moral instructions how do we
account for all that kind of for what
it's worth I'm not sure if this is how
you intend this but this to me is a much
better argument for Choice than test
scores in other words
um again I don't want to say I'm blight
about test scores because I want kids
all kids to learn how to read period
full stop
um but it frustrates me that we never
make that argument payments that you
tacitly just made in favor of choice the
argument we tend to make is oh Union
suck demand choice or or your local
school is charitable demand choice
wouldn't it be a more potent argument to
say look Mom and Dad nothing wrong with
with your local District school but
maybe you'd like a classical school or
maybe you'd like Kung Fu Academy or you
know maybe there's a thousand different
flavors of curriculum and instruction
one of which might be more interesting
to your child rather than having them
sit there bored all day that to me is
just a richer argument for Choice than
test scores bad choice good right and
just a demonization of unions as this
kind of you know we don't have the
Soviet Union to kick around anymore and
I say this I have a bunch of friends who
taught in public schools mostly in New
Jersey and they were union members and
they paid their dues and they were glad
to have the Union on certain levels but
they also were like God this Union sucks
so yeah you know I mean we're ale I
think as choice proponents and I'm not
necessarily saying you Robert I I speak
for myself here
um you know we're probably needlessly
alienated
almost as much as the kids yeah I I just
finished a 5000 word piece for National
Affairs that will come out in a couple
of weeks that makes precisely that
argument
um I I guess because I got bored of
sticking my thumb in Choice eyes now I'm
sticking my eyes my thumbs in
conservative's eyes
um you know I work at AEI this is
dangerous we're we're gonna ship you off
to their satellite campus in the green
zone and back it's gonna piss off
everybody before I'm done but I mean
this earnestly I mean another thing that
we tend to forget as Choice people or
you know in my case as as somebody more
right than left
um you know the vast majority of
American children go to public schools
and they always will at least in my
lifetime you know so so so it doesn't
make any sense to undermine these places
um to to to to turn parents against them
I mean maybe I've been reading you've
all live in too long but I'm kind of an
institutionalist and I'm interested in
public schools because that's where the
kids are so we we can't it can't be in
anyone's interest to crap all over them
and and delegitimize them you know we
should and again you can be a choice
person without withdrawing your interest
in in the public schools I think it's
just kind of and also if your argument
for that we haven't touched on this but
if your argument you hear this from some
guys at the Cato Institute is is oh this
is the solution to the culture War well
then if you if everybody who feels one
way about cultural War issues exits the
public school system you're
concentrating their effects among the
vast majority of American children who
are left behind that doesn't make any
sense to me whatsoever and just to put
some numbers on it uh you know I I have
a video that went up yesterday uh about
a kind of fictional schools of choice
that we all wanted to attend but it's
about uh less than 25 percent of
American students go to some School of
Choice whether it's a public charter
school or a magnet school something that
they choose to go home school private
school all of that it's a it's like a
little bit more than 75 percent is uh or
I'm sorry yeah uh because the chosen
public school like there's homeschooling
Etc but it's like overwhelmingly most
kids are still going to residential
assignment schools and you know that's
where the money is so yeah yeah and
that's where the kids are I mean I can't
be more emphatic about that the kids are
money let's face it you know okay but
I'm not sorry I'm not cynical enough to
just look at kids and see dollar signs I
see the kids who will be paying into
Social Security who will be fighting our
Wars who will be rebuilding our
Industries Etc the the idea that we
should wash our hands of ourselves you
know not at all I I'm joking but exactly
okay well I was just going to say first
of all let me just say that on a
personal level what you were saying
earlier I I resonate with that in terms
of it being just really appealing that
there's this kind of increasing menu of
options that fit different Lifestyles I
mean I see it in my neighborhood I live
in Florida which has a lot of school
choice in my neighborhood there's a
pretty good neighborhood school that's a
Technology Magnet my kids go to a kind
of like artsy like Waldorf inspired
school which I'm sure you would think
has total like garbage curriculum but I
like it I would think you would like the
wall right yeah no I I don't I don't I
don't like it or dislike it it's
perfectly fine
schools are better than the Waldorf
salad I just want to say that I'm a huge
Rudolph Steiner fan but that's that's
for a different live stream I I like it
because
um they're like consciously very like
tactile and like like sort of
anti-technology and the kids getting up
screen time like outside of school so I
don't want to also go home and have Rich
dinner table conversations with college
graduates which also build language
proficiency right right and then like
right across the street from that is
like a a science magnet a STEM Magnet
that's you know kind of the opposite
approach so it's kind of there's a kind
of beauty to seeing everyone be able to
like access all these different things
that that work best for them um and I
agree that that's kind of like the even
more powerful argument yeah is there an
upcoming Zach what's that there's a butt
coming isn't there you can say butt uh
no no there there's no butt coming I I
wanted the the well the objection that I
want to Levy at you was to the idea that
we still need to be heavily invested in
kind of the culture War uh wrangling
over curriculum
um because because so many kids are in
public school I mean you know these are
this is just some data a historical data
about about the rise in um Charter
School enrollment and you know there's
been a slow but steady upward Drive
you've documented in in your work Robert
that um you know a post-pandemic there's
been a acceleration accelerated you know
Exodus out of the public system I I part
of me just feels like the more that uh
Libertarians engage in like well what
should the
states determine the curriculum be the
more we are kind of impeding that that
that process or that progress towards
but can I just push back a little bit on
that I mean I don't necessarily disagree
with you but I I'm starting to feel like
my libertarian credentials were in
pretty good order until we became school
choice Advocates and now I feel that nit
is my friend Neil McCluskey about this
who who is a volcano Institute yeah
exactly uh and and he's written um a lot
about you know how how School choices
the antidote to to to to culture wars
and first I say well you know schools
are the original cultural War fronts you
know we argue yeah and and just to dump
on him right away yeah let me just
finish you know and I mean like you're
assuming if you if you have sent
yourself in this conversation you're
assuming the vast majority of American
kids who are left behind the public
system are going to always value
personal Liberty the way that you do and
so what I tease Neil with is saying you
know I don't want to read your future
book about gula's choice you know
because it could come to that in other
words you're you know you are assuming
that that the the Eternal values of
American society will always be in place
and they don't need stewardship and I
don't think that's right that's I mean I
was going to say that uh you know I I
think about this uh completely in terms
of religious freedom you know we have
and America has always been famous for
having lots of different religions and
subsex within you know Christianity
within Catholicism within you know
Judaism Etc and that doesn't diminish
culture War battles over religion what
it does is it stops the violence over
warring factions of religion and if we I
I look forward to a day when everybody
is going to a school of choice not
because it means we won't be arguing
over for what is right and proper or
effective or the Center of America but
will have richer conversations because
people don't have to you know you don't
get stuck doing something else in uh
Martin Morris Wooster a long time reason
contributor and author who wrote a great
book called angry classrooms vacant
Minds he died recently this was from
about 20 or 25 years ago it had a great
history of the Philadelphia school riots
in the pre-civil War era where the uh
you know the Wasps who ran the
Philadelphia establishment it was a big
Catholic town and they forced Catholic
schools to use the King James Bible and
it was this you know the people died in
the ensuing struggle that's yeah
ultimately on a certain level the
libertarian emphasis on choice I think
it's like okay it takes the violence out
of the system including the violence of
sending your kids to a school with whom
with whose curricula you kind of
disagree with fundamentally I think
that's good but it's not going to stop
these conversations but perhaps to bring
it back to uh something that Zach was
getting at as well is you know when you
talk about a Core curriculum
um like who who would decide that in you
know and and let's say you know 75 or
you know 70 of kids are going to be
going to residential assigned schools in
the state or the you know the state and
the local school boards are going to be
kind of calling the shots and the fed's
a little bit too but you know it's kind
of interesting to question like okay
well who's history because at some point
you've only got you know you've you've
got like 40 actual full school days in
the year they're always kind of nickel
and Diving it down but like you know you
can teach uh you know Zach are up in
Florida so it's like okay Ponce de Leon
is in but then maybe uh you know the
Rosewood Massacre of a black Town well
that's out because that's yeah you know
that's problematic and then you know
something about how orange juice is like
the greatest beverage ever is in
Walt Disney is a God no but I mean like
don't doesn't it make sense really from
a operational level to if the state is
going to dictate certain outcomes
you know those be minimal and if it's
going to dictate certain books and
things like that that really should be
pretty small
yeah I think that's probably right
um and and for what it's worth and I'm
going to be a little bit mealy-mouthed
on this I think it's more important to
build these uh foundations in the
elementary years so you can have these
witch debates and say middle school and
high school um so I'm probably a lot
more interested in being prescriptive to
the degree I'm interested at all in K to
five maybe K to eight but not in not in
high school
um so I I so but I mean look you know we
have a mechanism for the for
adjudicating these debates right now
Nick can you just alluded to it we've
got 13 000 school boards we got 50
states
in 1950 we had like 114 000 school
districts yeah you know so it's like in
a bizarre way uh you know I mean I mean
the consolidation and centralization of
Education in America like from you know
after World War II was immense and
phenomenal and that's also not a bad
thing too because like most of those
school districts you know were probably
absolutely
segregated and they also probably had uh
you know our uh reason science
correspondent Ron Bailey grew up in
Virginia in the 60s uh I guess late 50s
and early 60s and he showed us some of
us on slack his he had his uh Elementary
School history book and it was literally
filled with happy slaves who weren't
called slaves either you know they were
like Happy Farm hands or something and
it's like wow like that that is an
argument for like I don't want anybody
to be in control because the possibility
of system failure is really bad and you
know Zach do we want to talk now uh
given where you know you're in Florida
about the African-American uh studies AP
course like yeah how does that factor in
10 well yeah I mean I wanted to ask both
of you your reaction to that this
specific example which is that here in
Florida
um Ron DeSantis
um uh banned a AP African-American uh
studies or history course I have a a
clip here that I'll I'll pull up with
him in a second explaining why he
thought that was necessary
um but this is kind of part of his broad
campaign to quote unquote de wokify uh
Florida schools um and you know Robert
I'd like to get into your thoughts of
what has happened to uh the kind of
public school curricula you you call it
uh the pedagogy of the depressed so I
want to talk about like how we got there
at some point and what your analysis is
of you know why it's a problem but first
let me just play this clip of DeSantis
and get your reaction DeSantis said
teaching black history is required in
Florida schools but added this course
amounted to indoctrination this course
on black history what are one what's one
of the lessons about queer Theory now
who would say that an important part of
black history street is queer theory
that is somebody pushing an agenda on
our kids and so when you look to see
they have stuff about intersectionality
abolishing prisons that's a political
agenda
um and then this is from NBC News uh
obtained the uh the course material uh I
think you know the what he's objecting
to seems to be you know like in unit
four you can see things like uh the
black feminist movement womanism and
intersectionality
um I don't know black lives today
anti-colonial movements and military
service I don't know uh I guess like my
my general sense is you know this is a
High School AP class you can kind of opt
into it or not if you like I don't know
why the governor needs to weigh in but
you know what what do you think why did
the governor weigh in because am I
reading the Constitution incorrectly or
is is education no longer under State
Control
uh okay that's why he's doing it well I
mean I'm sure he's got political reasons
for it but right right and again I I
don't want to sound blight here but I
mean I'm surprised when people are
surprised about things like this so I
mean I I don't know look let me just say
I don't know that I'm I'm not
necessarily questioning his
constitutional authority to do so I'm
questioning the wisdom of yeah Governor
kind of micromanaging what can be in
high school curricula or or not um I
mean is that yeah well and I'm not
trying to to gain say that
um because again as I keep saying I'm a
choice guy okay I'm a choice guy I'm
much more concerned in American
Education with the opposite problem of
having classroom teachers feeling that
they are free as public employees as
state actors to close the door and teach
whatever the hell they want okay I think
that I'm not neither one of these are
are good uh things to have but I think
the the problem of no curriculum of
indulging your priors of viewing your
job as no I'm not a teacher I'm a I'm
I'm an activist I think think that's a
bigger problem particularly in so far as
it is it it damages trust in public
education
not asking for Walmart schools but I do
think that whether you live in Florida
Ohio New York or anywhere else there
should be a certain kind of reasonable
set of expectations about the the
content of your kids education that are
met regardless of where you are so I
mean in like say k through weight uh
education is that a big problem that the
teachers you know they get a curriculum
and they shut the door and they say hey
we're not teaching this I'm just gonna
you know free write about your
experience that's not the problem at all
the bigger problem is there's no
curriculum whatsoever serious I mean and
when you say that like you know they
don't get assigned textbooks or they
don't get assigned worksheets and things
well let's take this back to what we
were saying at the top about leading
instruction and then stop me if I told
you this story before Nick but one of my
first days in the classroom my Lucy
Hawkins uh professional development
staffer when I said what am I supposed
to teach you you're the best person to
know what every child needs and I
thought she was making fun of me okay
but but what she what she meant was that
you're here to teach the skill of
reading and what you choose is well what
you picture what year what year was that
and that's in in New York City
yeah and the New York City School
District which is the largest school
district in the country
um yeah and you know and so you went
into class and they weren't like here's
the textbook here's the reader here's
you know thick run book or whatever and
like you can start a question library
and I was to teach the skill you know of
reading and writing so to today you know
I would I would model for my students
you know when Good readers read they
notice what characters say now in the
books that you're reading notice what
the characters say and and this is my
point about teaching reading as a skill
okay right uh where you're not teaching
any set text whatsoever there's the the
mini lesson the skill du jour then kids
24 kids 24 books they go off and
practice the skill oil which isn't a
skill at all independently right part of
the point of charter schools early on
was the the experimentation would
supposedly develop some best practices
that then could be applied
um in the public schools or not the
public schools in the district schools
to what extent has that happened
um I mean you know again Success Academy
is an example of one network where
they've gotten pretty remarkable results
have district schools learn from
anything from the successful Charters
and applied them in their curricula not
enough and and at the risk of getting
down into the weeds you know since you
kindly alluded to my book I mean that
was the that was the reason I wrote that
book because I wanted to spend a year in
this extremely high performing Charter
district and say okay what are the
lessons here that we can apply to K-12
at large another do what we were
supposed to be doing
good news bad news the bad news was I
didn't find a whole lot of lessons
um that's that's the bad news the good
news is is is one of the lessons that I
think and this may have been
confirmation bias in my part but what I
really liked and I think really is
applicable to K-12 whether it's a school
choice a school of choice or a district
school is the way they conceived of the
role of the teacher
um and I did this as a teacher as well
you spend an ungodly amount of time when
you don't have a curriculum crafting
lessons on your own going on Google and
Pinterest and looking for you know
lessons or materials to engage interest
your kids and that time that is time I'm
not spending getting to know my kids
looking at their work becoming expert in
the curriculum building a relationship
with families all of these other things
that that yield more value at Success
Academy they they have a curriculum
they've got the the their their
preparation time is what they call
intellectual preparation preparing to
teach the lesson not creating it from
scratch so that creates more bandwidth
to do all of those other things I mean I
don't think that's the only reason
success kind of blows the doors off
standardized testing but the conception
they have of what a teacher's job is and
what a teacher's job is not is one of
those things that I think school well
the other thing that you found I mean
the the big takeaway the the kind of
headline uh controversy making was that
uh Success is Not skimming good students
that's the that's the charge that's
lobbed at all successful Charter Schools
yeah but it's that it really selects for
a highly motivated parents and that's a
big de facto I mean you can't you
literally cannot hand pick families but
they create any number of mechanisms
that make it more likely that active
engaged families will persist yes
um so okay go ahead we returned to this
question of what has happened to
curricula beyond the problems with
Basics like reading and arithmetic
um you penned this article in commentary
the unbearable bleakness of schooling
and you write there that uh this
pedagogy of the pressed America the
problematic is thought to be a virtue
among professional Educators who view it
as a mark of seriousness and
sophistication we want children to
Grapple with quote honest history close
quote starting in elementary school and
to discover the power of their voices by
writing authentic essays about their
personal problems
um what what is the pedagogy of the
depressed
and how did this overtake or what to
what degree did it overtake the
curricula in in public schools and and
how did it happen yeah or the pedagogy
of the depressed as Nick will appreciate
it was kind of a little inside joke
um you know because all of us as
teachers had to study Paolo Freire in
his book The pedagogy of the oppressed
so this was just my having a little bit
of a of a laugh at that and turning it
on its ear
um look you know I I think you could
write a really good book about education
about you you know how how we are
sometimes wrong for all the right
reasons and and this is a a good example
of that so the reading curriculum like
who thinks kids shouldn't be engaged by
what they read of course they should but
then you're missing something profound
so so you know it makes a lot of sense
that oh you should challenge kids you
should make the curriculum about them
they should write about things that
matter to them they should learn about
problems in the world so they are you
know inspired to to do their part to
build a more perfect union all these
things sound you know engaging and
exciting and as adults it's you know
this is what we do all day this sounds
great well I I do worry that for
children it's overwhelming you know that
that that the world begins to appear to
them is nothing more than just it's all
bad and broken and and wait a minute
you're asking me I'm to fix this I'm 12.
you know where are the grown-ups what
what what's your role in all this so I I
don't want to overstate the problem but
but nor do I want to understate the
problem you know yes we want students to
be problem solvers but that doesn't mean
that Educators should be problem
fetishizers and I think that's what's
happening what are these specific you
know you know what is the Core
Curriculum the kind of Cultural Literacy
of depression that is being taught is it
um you know is it that America was
founded you know as a white supremacist
uh you know Club Med or something is it
that the environment that the planet you
know that the planet is irredeemable
it's it's burned to a crisp but you
still gotta you know separate your
Plastics and paper I mean what what are
the what are the lessons that are being
taught yeah and again I don't want to
overstate that but I do think that we
are airing on the side of of painting a
picture of the world as as bad and
broken and you decided some of the
examples you know like oh the the the
plan is going to be uninhabitable in 12
years wait I'm 12. that's going to be a
problem
um you know you look at the world of
young adult literature all this stuff
that is supposed to be engaging in
interesting to kids well you know it
sometimes it's like those old you know
TV movies of the week where you know the
the pathology du jour I mean it's it's
all about you know drug use and sexual
abuse and racism and whatnot I mean it's
it's just it it's I don't think I'm I'm
wrong to suggest that we we are
sometimes guilty of presenting kids a
view of the world that is awfully dark
we are oftentimes and when I say wave
Robert I'm going to include you in this
baby boomers have internalized and are
projecting out anxieties uh in a way
maybe maybe our parents generation was a
little bit more stoic uh you know in a
lot of ways um well no look you and I
are roughly the same age Nick and in
that commentary piece I think I I wrote
about this think of the world in which
we grew up okay I grew up on Long Island
I can't remember where you grew I uh
well I'm sorry well speak slower
[Laughter]
you know toxic dump sites think of the
world of the late 60s early 70s okay
um there was it was a time of tremendous
unrest you think it's bad now in terms
of political unrest in in Brian
Burroughs book days of Rage he
chronicled 1900 domestic bombings in a
single year I think 1971. can you
imagine if that was happening right
Christian pollution was through the roof
the economy was in the my dad
was a metric system the metric system
was about to be imposed my dad worked
for the Airlines and and the the news
was filled with you know hijackings and
watching yeah but I didn't have the
sense that I lived in a dangerous the
Vietnam War was going on yeah nuclear
Annihilation it was like yeah yeah did
you have the sense that the world was
somehow no no
if anything it was you know no not at
all well why is that I'm not saying that
I have the answer but I'm I'm very
curious about what change in American
life and culture that we grew up in what
by comparison to today genuinely
unsettled and dangerous times but it but
it we didn't have that sense as kids now
things are you know look I'm sorry
there's never been a more prosperous
better time to be alive if you look at
by every reasonable measure of human
happiness than now and we think things
have never been worse and somehow we
think kids are immune from this come on
yeah uh you know the one thing I'll say
though
um it does seem as if uh and you know
maybe this is off base but that the the
typical school now seems to be teaching
toward a history of grievance which is
Rich and meaningful but for blacks for
uh lower lower income people Etc and
that the difficulties that they face I
do know that you know the Catholic
school that I went to taught an
alternative history of America that I
didn't realize until I went to college
was pretty pretty weird where Catholics
were simultaneously the most oppressed
group and also the most important and
Central to American history and American
flourishing so it was kind of you know
it wasn't quite Marcus Garvey Academy or
something but it was a form of lower
middle class which is the melu I grew up
in of recent immigrant Catholic Heritage
that was uplifting and that was like you
know what we made it here and
it's better than the uh than Old Europe
and you know you got some real you got
some real uh you know options in front
of you but in a way that's not all that
different than maybe you know uh you
know lower income black kids learning a
history that is generally denied
um and uh yeah this is one of those
areas that that is too volatile to paint
with a broad brush so I'm I'm not going
to but but I will say here's what
concerns me I mean you know I joke that
my side hustle is civic education I I do
worry about
um look at if public education
um does nothing else it ought to attach
kids to Civil Society right you know
regardless of your politics regardless
of your of your you know religious or
ethnic background you you know if we do
nothing else kids should leave us from
every school even schools of choice at
age 17 or 18 excited to get on with
something you know I don't care if it's
College military job whatever but they
should feel invested you know in their
community in their country and eager to
do their part you know so we were
talking earlier about you know
accountabilities act there's your
accountability okay kids should the the
and I've written about this before like
the the only accountability that matters
is if you say to kids are you in you
know and they and they say yes and
here's what they're excited to do how
would you measure that though can I
finish this thought because what I worry
about and I don't natter on about
grieving studies but but if your entire
history if your entire K-12 education
was just chock full of grievance and the
bad and the broken where's the incentive
to feel like you're bought in and eager
to do something we think as teachers
that it's a mark of our sophistication
that we're inspiring kids to take their
part and fix these things when it may
have exactly the opposite effect my AEI
colleague Yuval Levin has written about
this about you know about that what he
calls the new social disorder and it's
not an excess of passion for you know
sex and drugs and money and whatnot it's
just the opposite it's this Failure to
Launch it's the why bother I'm sitting
on the couch I'm not bought into
anything
do you have a sense of how much the
concerns about this especially parental
concerns are actually driving both the
The Exodus from public education which
you mentioned in the same article uh 600
school districts in nearly two dozen
states found a decline of three percent
in public school enrollment compared
with pre-pandemic levels including about
50 000 students gone missing in New York
City 26 000 in La 25 000 in Chicago all
told about 1.5 million students have
exited the traditional public education
we don't know why I don't know why I
mean yeah go ahead no I was gonna say
it's funny you should bring this up
because just two days ago I was asking
uh about this very question like we know
that there's been this Exodus but we
know why they're leaving and I I can't
find a good answer to it it could be job
related it could be
um you know I'm dismayed with Public
Schools I'm going to homeschool my kid
because the homeschooling numbers are
way up uh I I don't think we've got good
data we can be make some intelligent
guesses but I don't think we've got good
data about why when parents are leaving
why they've chosen to leave I mean
another one is I mean just from personal
experience and anecdotal from you know
living in La through this that's where I
was when the pandemic hit
um you know the the going all virtual
with the schools did a few things it
first of all forced this sort of
curriculum transparency uh secondly
getting back into it
um I mean a big issue for me was I had a
big problem with kind of the health
mandates that were being imposed on my
very young children that was a big
motivator for me and I think a lot of
other parents
um whether it's you know children
wearing masks Outdoors out day all day
without much justification or like the
threats of certain man
um uh vaccine mandates and stuff like
that
um and then just like the general way
that the teachers union was
um behaving through out all this I don't
know how Salient that is for people who
aren't as like politically engaged as me
but the fact that they were advocating
to keep the schools closed until this
like laundry list of Demands was met
that was awesome what are you talking
about Randy Randy Weingarten was was
working very hard to reopen space she
said so herself
and just the unpredictability right I
mean in a lot of places schools would be
open then they were shut then there were
no question for two days a week for you
but three days for the other kids Etc it
was like a really good
and we don't like to to to to to talk
about that among those of us who are
like sophisticated about education but
come on people need a safe place for
their kid to be all day right and when
and so it's not just the school closures
it was the quarantines right so when
schools reopened then suddenly one kid
tests you know uh it wasn't even in your
kids class but was on the bus one kid
test positive for covet and everybody
stays home for two weeks
we do kind of need schools to be
reliably open or closed so we can make
plans and get on with our life yeah and
so people
um also got a taste of trying things a
different way some people might have
tried some homeschooling or they did
these micro School pods I mean I don't
know if that's contributed to people
thinking some people like remote
learning Zach you know I mean and then
maybe it's been a disaster but for some
families it worked pretty well
yoga Zach I just wonder like how much of
this
um you know
is going to last in terms of people
being open to different ways of doing
things I mean yeah I think it's a great
question yeah can we get together next
year and answer it because I'm planning
on spending the next year in places like
Arizona and Iowa and West Virginia that
are going kind of all in on esa's
because I think this is the real promise
you know it's it's you know it's one
thing to say I've got choice and now
I've even got a backpack full of cash
it's another question to say okay what
am I going to do with it right you know
so um I brought up some um slides here
of these are just some recent moves that
have been made in that regard so you
mentioned Arizona which I think was the
first state to pass an educational
savings account law which allows you to
make it Universal there's a lot of laws
but the difference in Arizona is now
everybody can do it yes thank you for
that
um uh there's uh here we've got uh Iowa
just signed one
um it's been proposed Florida it's been
proposed West Virginia legislature are
past it so this is definitely there's
there's a lot of momentum there
um you say you're going to go there and
investigate it what kind of questions uh
do you have about educational savings
it's just that and I'm gonna I'm gonna
you know take my own advice on this in
other words it's it's it's not as
interesting to me like public school bad
private school good or Charter School
good I I want to know I mean look the
the libertarian gloss on this is once
you give parents you know the backpack
full of cash they can they can Chinese
menu so to speak or a la carte their way
to a good education you know by by
picking and choosing different providers
and and and programs and whatnot I think
that's interesting and and worthwhile
but I think that's going to be mostly at
the high end
um so I'm kind of interested uh for both
good and bad what kind of
entrepreneurial dynamism does this
inject into a system so I I said this to
somebody yesterday if I were a much
younger person I'd move to Arizona right
now and I'd start myself a low a
low-cost Ed Hearst core knowledge
private school you know the the the
school of my dreams you know and and I'd
figure out a way to to price it at that
seven thousand dollar you know per
family or per kid price point to to make
it work
um so it uh surely I can't be the only
person who sees that opportunity I just
wrote a piece yesterday for the dispatch
about Great Hearts Academy which is a
terrific network of charter schools
um they haven't announced this yet but
but they've they've confirmed that they
are launching a a network of private
Christian academies now aimed at
low-income you know kids starting in
August so in other words uh people who
are in this work should should do what
great hearts are they they predictably I
would I would predict will do what Great
Hearts is doing which is saying there's
now this mechanism what does this enable
us to do that will serve families better
so are you are you confident that the uh
you know that the supply is going to
grow to uh either increase demand or or
you know satisfy it because this was
something
you know I I think a year ago or so I
talked with Chris Stewart the you know
who's a education uh kind of critic uh
and school choice advocate in Minnesota
and he was saying you know what when the
pandemic hit the big failure was that
there was not the there were not the
schools ready like people in the school
Choice Movement have been saying for a
long time you know we you know we can
handle it and they couldn't but this
gives them the money right so are you
confident that do you think that's
remarkable either if it doesn't then
then there's a theoretical problem with
that way of looking at schools right I
mean in other words this this should be
if you're a Milton Friedman guy this
should be exactly what you want you're
now creating the conditions for the
market to respond so what's the market
going to do yeah what do you think if
anything this will do for higher end
education or if we can talk a little bit
about this because you know you know
when you look at a high-end education
private schools or effect effectively
you know high-end private schools in
towns or whatever that have you know
that have income levels and zoning and
everything to keep it like that are they
are they the incubators of the worst
kind of curricula excesses partly
because they know that their kids can
learn nothing
from K through 12 or K through 24 you
know years of school because they're
going to be okay like they have the rich
conversations at home they have you know
books everywhere Etc and is it is it
partly that the rot in education
including this you know dismissal of
core of Cultural Literacy it's really
coming from the top end uh rather than
something that like middle class people
or or minority activists are are pushing
yeah this is another a dicey subject I
mean um my daughter went to one of these
elite private schools two of them you
know end to end and candidly uh I have
joked over the years that her attendance
was the price of Peace in my marriage
because I was a public school kid my
wife was a private school girl I'd get
divorced today before I'd say before I'd
send my daughter to the two schools that
she attended period
um and this is the challenge for Choice
Theory as well right in other words if
you think about it and I assume we're
talking about these these these super
Elite schools which by the way probably
won't esa's won't make a difference it's
a rounding error on on the amount of
money that these that these cause and so
they'll take the money and apply it but
but you know it's not going to change
their behavior
um but this is a threat in my mind to
Choice Theory right so if you were
suggesting okay the the kinds of parents
who send their kids to these super Elite
Upper East Side you know Bethesda
whatever Maryland uh private schools
these are folks who have the most
options the most choices the most
resources and they are making a choice
that frankly many of the parents dislike
okay super woke schools and all they do
is they sit there and see and and they
don't why don't they get up and change
well okay you tell me why they don't get
up and change because the function is
what you alluded to yeah
it's great yeah and the function of the
education system is not to challenge the
existing class structure it's to
replicate it I mean I think both public
and private I'm very Marxist uh on that
uh on that front so I you know I was at
a dinner I had dinner with David Mamet
once the uh you know the playwright who
bitched and moaned that his kids all
went to Crossroads which was you know
started in Santa Monica as an
alternative hip you know very elite
private school for Hollywood kids and
he's like oh they learn nothing they
learned nothing but it was like well why
didn't you send your kids to a better
school and he's like what can you do you
know it's like you know and it's like
yeah no and it's like because you want a
signal that your kids are going to
Crossroads codes Etc and all of this
it's like there you go can I ask and um
you know we are we have gone over time
and I appreciate you staying with us
because uh you know we did have
technical difficulties and stuff and
whatnot but
um how do you know in in a lot of ways
the question about education or maybe
this is framing it wrong but it is how
do you help you know and maybe it's the
bottom 10 or the bottom 20 of kids who
are coming from lower income or or lower
opportunity households like those are
the people where school can be education
can be the real Difference Maker in
their lives because if your middle class
or upper middle class it's like school
is kind of a tax that you pay you know
like your your parents pay and you're
you're going to be pretty good anyway
but you know how do how do we make sure
that those people really have the
ability to
um you know kind of participate in as
fully in the American experiment I mean
I think this is the best rhetoric of
public schools like how do we how do we
make sure they're not you know just
forgotten yeah no look I said thank you
that's a great question and it's a great
question to close on and just very
quickly Nick I I don't want to be quite
as blight about high-end and middle
income kids your point is well taken
their their outcomes are not guaranteed
it is the way to bet however right but
that that bottom 10 as you like it look
the these are the kids that that my
career has been predicated upon helping
them and this is this is why I think
that choice will help them but I'm not
necessarily I'm I'm definitely not
convinced it's a Magic Bullet and and I
think this is a real Achilles heel and
choice theory if the if the idea is that
if you set everybody free they will make
good decisions many will some will not
and this is also why I'm not abandoning
the public school system because that's
as a practical matter where those kids
are going to end up right
um so you know I I'm not going to sit
here and pretend that I have the answer
but I think this is a challenge for all
of us who think of ourselves as Choice
Advocates is he a damn well better be
thinking about those kids because it
doesn't take a great deal of imagination
to realize let's say a year from now
you've got not just three states as Esa
States but 30 okay and everybody is now
suddenly in charge
um you know or you fast forward to the
day when when parents are in control of
of of this spending but then it turns
out that we've created you know not we
have an underclass right now but a
profound underclass among people who are
not just poorly educated but not
educated at all well there goes choice
for generation or maybe more so if we're
not thinking about those kids shame on
us
I mean I guess I it's
hard for me to see why that would be the
outcome I mean what's playing prevent it
Zach
wouldn't I there's what's going to
prevent people from going to a school
where their kids are just not learning
anything
or just basically opting out of the
system altogether I'm taking my ESA
money and oh there's this provider and
yeah sure but then you know in other
words if you're cobbling together you
know we we assume that that you know uh
engaged active educated parents will
make good choices well are you going to
deny the ability of of of of uh lower
income low SES parents to make those
same decisions so you're saying uh
people just cobbling together a kind of
homeschool type curriculum that just is
totally worthless yeah that okay exactly
I was misunderstanding yeah well I was
just I know you're always understanding
I was being insufficiently clear do you
um you know one of the Hallmarks I've
you know for a song I've been at reason
for 29 years and have always been
interested in school choice and whatnot
and one of the things that I've always
heard that's actually well it's
complicated it describes my parents as
well who were not educated but that
low-income parents you know they want
educate in in the main they want better
education for the kids they want better
opportunities and they're pretty good
good at that and that's I mean certainly
in particularly in urban areas
um you know it seems like the early
experiments with vouchers and things
like that in places like Milwaukee and
Dayton and uh you know a couple other
places you know that seemed to be the
case I like there's a lot of motivated
low-income parents sure um you know so
maybe it will take care of itself but I
guess part of it is that we really have
to wait and see what's going on I think
one thing that has to be you know
anticipated is that this is already a
critique that is very common and you see
from people such as John Oliver did a
big uh thing uh going after Charter
Schools about six or seven years ago
um and the thrust of his argument was
look at this particular bad Charter over
here or this one over here and it just
closed after you know less than a year
and then these kids are left twisting uh
in the wind and I mean the theory of of
you know school choice people is like
well that's kind of the process of
choices you're weeding out the bad
schools and to the degree that it's
causing even you know district schools
that shouldn't be open to close that's
that's actually good but there is
something to his argument that you know
if you're the person who has your kid in
that school when it closes down that's
extremely disruptive to your life I mean
what is the is there any way to like
what's the best way to cope with and
yeah I don't think there's a perfect
answer here and this is why there's kind
of got to be almost I mean to use a
legal analogy like almost joint and
several accountability like my Arizona
friends love to point to Arizona
Charters as having solved this because
in Most states I think it takes five
years to get your Charter renewed and in
Arizona I believe it's 15 and he Matt
Ladner and others have pointed out that
um by the time the year 15 rolls around
parents have long since voted with their
feet okay and that's that's probably
right but it's not a guarantee uh
because again we're talking about kind
of Boutique very small numbers of
schools and students would that work
nationally
I don't know you know I mean I think
look there's there's no substitute for
increased parental sophistication you
know and if there's been a theme to this
conversation it's none of these
mechanisms work
um by themselves there's no perpetual
motion machine here you've got to create
the conditions that that you know in
that that creates parental not just
choice but sophistication about these
things I mean the analogy I always use
is if you go to your pediatrician and
they send you home with a prescription
by the time you get home you've already
looked on WebMD you know about you know
all the side effects of what your
pediatricians are offering you we don't
do that with education you know in fact
I would I would bet my last dollar that
if you pull even sophisticated parents
about hey what's the ELA curriculum at
your kid's school eight out of ten
wouldn't even know
right and or how to evaluate it so let
me let's end on this note uh which maybe
just you can dismiss it as well but you
know one of the things that the national
assessment of educational progress does
you know going back to the early 70s the
tracks kind of student scores uh they've
been pretty flat and depending on how he
calculated we're spending two to three
times as much per pupil in real
inflation-adjusted terms is it just that
kids are Dumber now
that we have to spend more and more
money on them to keep them at the same
or slightly lower level than when you
and I Robert were you know in short
pants Zach was not quite born yet at his
SATs I guarantee you are better than
mine probably yours you know but but no
but I mean is it is it a yeah no that's
for sure is it I mean you know it it's a
it's a weird thing like are we are we
obsessing over education in a way and
I'm joking about kids just being Dumber
but you know because education you know
going back to Socrates you know
educating the young is absolutely filled
with existential anxiety of every
society and you know so is all of this
just kind of like you know we're just we
got a lot of nervous energy and a lot of
money to spend and a lot of time to
argue but you know actually the kids are
doing okay
uh I I don't think the kids are doing
okay and I don't want to be alarmist
about this something we haven't even
touched on is mental health you know and
if you talk to John Hyde and Greg
Luciano and others they'll say it's it's
the screen is stupid and I think there's
a compelling case for for the
deleterious effects of social media and
technology and whatnot you know so it's
almost impossible to separate schools
from all the other effects in kids lives
um do I think kids have gotten some real
kids have not gotten Dumber kids have
gotten smarter
um do I think we have gotten
accidentally less good at educating them
probably uh and and it probably has to
do with some of the factors we talked
about earlier Nick about how it was
there didn't used to be a lot of
question about what you did in school
all day and the more sophisticated we've
gotten in terms of trying to raise
levels of you know problem solving and
critical thinking we've actually got
made it worse not better you've got the
issue of of who becomes a teacher
um you know uh nobody should want women
to to to to leave Law and medicine and
whatnot and go back into the classroom
but but if you think about I'll bet like
you like me Nick some of your teachers
in retrospect were women who today would
have been doing much more renumerative
things than they did 40 or 50 years ago
it's a gordian not you know I I'm taking
Austin you know the amount of
environmental lead was so much higher
you know and Lead gets a bad rap but I
don't know when you know when we were
chewing on lead paint and breathing in
lead gasoline air fumes I don't know
what seemed to be doing better as a uh
as a society yeah look the one this will
be my Parting Shot I guess the the one
if if I could make one change in
American Education now it would probably
be and this gets to the idea of is it
getting it is is it getting worse I
think what's changes our expectations
have gotten um uh outsized for American
education and and most specifically what
I mean by that is we literally expect
too much not of education but of
teachers we keep asking them to do more
and more and the same and look I mean
this is the the last hill I'll die on in
education I point this out all the time
you've got four million American men and
women in classrooms every day if you
have four million of anybody doing
anything by definition you're going to
have a normal range of human capacity in
in a number that large so you've got to
make that job doable by those people the
Cavalry isn't coming there are not
enough Saints and Superstars to to fill
all those classrooms we've got to
reconceive the job of of teacher to be
doable by men and women of ordinary
sentience because that's who we have and
that's all we're ever going to have so
if the job can't be done well by those
people you you don't have a plan it's a
prayer
yeah all right that's a uh sober but uh
resounding note to end on Robert
pondicio you're at American Enterprise
Institute where's the best place that
people can follow your reading we'll
have something in the uh show notes and
stuff but uh yeah at AEI or just on
Twitter pretty much everything I write
ends up on on my Twitter
[Music]
yeah yeah thank you Zach wise Miller as
always thanks for uh staging a great
conversation thank you enjoy the
gentleman thanks for having me